[Music]
our Cassie doloro was on the carpet with
the voice family tonight Blake Shelton
says goodbye to the show for good it
sounds like Blake Shelton is in for
quite the send-off
star-studded lineup including Adam
Levine coming back to send you off how
do you feel about that I think that's
the only bad idea that the producers
have had you know because everything
else feels like exciting and then they
say Adam's coming back and everybody's
like well you know can't be perfect
it'll be fine I I hope they don't let
him talk hey Blake but I still hate you
how are you sending him off are you
gonna miss him oh we're gonna we're
gonna have a few drinks anyway no I
doubt I'm gonna miss him big time like I
made a friend over like it's just been a
laugh the whole season don't be asking
me to be your mentor
not going
the family is excited to have you home
more more family time and that's really
what especially this next chapter is
going to be like for you right it is for
me you know I mean I I want to to
finally have the opportunity to to just
say yes to a bunch of stuff in my
personal life I'm super excited about
that part but before he says farewell
Blake is hoping to win the
win the O for a 10th time he's got two
artists in the finale Niall and Kelly
each have one and chance has a sister
Trio I'm not worried about Blake's
sympathy vote as much as I am like he's
got like some sort of weird control over
the show if anything goes Haywire just
know Blake did cheat for sure for Nile
the final five reveal brought back some
One Direction memories and when he was
discovered on The X Factor I was getting
so many flashbacks of being on you know
being on the show I was on and just
stood there on stage waiting for the
results to be read out it was intense
oh